to use liberal speak i am a person of
color i guess you can say that the irony
is this dude should be the left's
biggest idol they want you looking up to
somebody like cardi b so you can say
right where you are or worse
this is part one of tucker carlson today
interview with mr andrew tate tate's
return from his final message took a
real long break lasted like a whole five
minutes he slept negative one minutes
and jumped right on i sleep negative one
minutes i don't need sleep stop the cow
for those of you that don't know tucker
carlson it is tucker time is my favorite
part of the day it's tucker time take a
time let's go styling welcome to tucker
carlson today andrew tate suddenly the
most famous man on the internet and then
all of a sudden gone from the internet a
few days ago banned by virtually every
social media app on the internet around
the world for reasons that no one
explained and that are still not clear
lots of mean things being written about
andrew tate but we have learned over
time to trust our own experience don't
believe what you hear go right to the
source starting to have some conspiracy
theories about how this happened right
at the same time that zuckerberg came
out and and told joe rogan that he was
feeling pressured by the fbi to to hide
the hunter biden laptop story on
facebook so i feel like maybe there's
some
bigger forest happening behind the
social media
world and i'm probably not going to be
too eloquent with this but they know
that by banning tate they're making tate
more famous you think they know that
they're doing that of course they know
they know they're not these are these
are really brilliant people you gotta be
ashamed of yourself [ __ ]
real talk you got to be ashamed of
yourself old as you is tate's getting a
bigger platform and i'm just kind of
wondering in an oversimplified way if
these big tech companies are being
pressured to correct the mess that they
have helped to create because they're
realizing that the country and the world
has gone completely haywire because of
their [ __ ] and they have to push it
back to the middle they have to help and
i can't help but think there's a bigger
a bigger thing at play here that's gonna
so you think it's intentional to ban
tate to then give him a bigger platform
and save people i think it just might be
what the [ __ ] uh who knows i don't know
why not just sit here and make up
conspiracy i got a lot of
intro i gotta look more into this
zuckerberg thing so i'm not really too
sure about that but oh it's definitely
possible that they did we should react
to that too because that's i wonder if
he like knew he was going to get banned
and that he incorporated that into his
plan who knows i'm sure he had a
contingency plan just in case that
happened okay let's go andrew tate
himself who is joining us as far as we
know from bucharest romania entertain
thanks so much for coming on
top thank you very much for having me
tucker
of course so why do you think and this
is a sincere question because i don't
know the answer why do you think you
were banned from the internet
i was banned from the internet for
having massive influence over the youth
and for not aligning myself with the
liberal degeneracy in which they want me
to purport to the young people of the
world today
so i i i i want to get much deeper into
that but i just immediately immune
by the phrase liberal degeneracy because
of course they're accusing you of
getting generally in every day so you're
saying that you exposed how degenerate
they are and they are of course
completely degenerate what did you say
that they couldn't tolerate well this is
the thing that's interesting i don't
really feel like i've exposed anything
like i'm truly
not a very political person this is the
first time someone's experienced this
level of ban i'm not particularly
right-wing i don't vote i mean i
obviously have my own personal views but
they didn't ban me for that
they banned me simply because
i had large swaths of the population
agreeing to very traditional masculine
values
teenage men and young and young men 20
30 22 23 24
were looking up to me and aspiring to be
like me i have a very traditionally
masculine life
i have fast cars and a big house and a
lot of money and a beautiful girlfriend
and they thought they thought this was
very very threatening he has like 10
beautiful girlfriends reason they
decided that it's better if they
annihilate me from the internet and
replace me with somebody who's more
aligned with
whatever they're trying to purport
i i sense that what you're saying is
right again i don't really know i
um
but it's crazy how like nobody really
knows like we all have the same feeling
that there's some greater thing that's
going on but like not even like even
tate's thing like he doesn't know
tucker's like yeah i agree but i don't
really know and that's tucker carlson
you know what i mean it's pretty wild
it's like who the [ __ ] it's coming out
it's coming out the puppet masters dude
because like you've been running a
company in the crypto space holy [ __ ]
like the stuff that you see behind the
scenes and how it's the same people
scamming multiple different projects the
same scam coins you see it's like you
know it's the same people and all the
same investors like i don't know
it is just weird to see the behind the
scenes and how convinced people can be
like that follow it and then so like
that it makes perfect sense like this
stuff to me because i've had that
experience in business and i've seen how
the people can be so compliant and
brainwashed by the companies and the
[ __ ] it's the same scammers at the
top yeah it makes sense to me people are
sadly easily easy to manipulate until
they are educated yeah and that's why
they don't want us educated i butchered
that but i have to be careful with what
i said and yeah you got your brain point
across it's cool let's go flush it out a
bit why would
your
message your lifestyle be so threatening
to the people who banned you
yeah it's an interesting question
because i've been banned under the guise
of misogyny and dangerous person and
this is the first time this has ever
happened like i said before whenever
this was happened there was political
affiliation and
now there really isn't
and it's a very slippery that's what you
said like when they banned trump he was
he was going after the most important
seat in the world with this dude he's
just literally saying traditional values
and they ban them because they're that
scared of it getting out it's insane
yeah but if but if enough people adopt
traditional values and want strength and
self-reliance that will have a political
effect it will have a political effect
and they know that again they know that
so by banning him making him more
popular it makes me think that they are
actually regretting what they the
monster they've created and they now
want to correct it i already know what
kate's phase three is you know yes he's
going to become president that that's
his phase three he's an american-born
citizen he could run for president and
he'd win there's no way he'd lose who
would beat take sleepy joe sleepy joe
[ __ ] absolutely not imagine tate in a
debate with joe biden he would rip his
head off slope i mean it's dangerous
enough when they're doing it to
political rivals but when they start
doing it to anybody who simply says
anything they don't like of on any under
any label then this is the beginning of
a large wave of censorship which is
incoming
they said i'm misogynistic
they said that i say things which are
degrading and damaging to women i
strongly reject that point
what i do is i try and stick up for men
and what i do is i try and advertise to
the world and to the young men of the
world that they should avoid low quality
people of all genders
and through clever censoring of me
discussing
uh important issues about men and
through clever editing of some of my
videos from very long format into very
very short format they've managed to
media spin and report the lie that i am
some woman hating misogynist okay that's
what they do that's what they do to
everybody and what's it used to just be
the major media outlets that were doing
that and now as we've heard tate say it
happens everybody's got editing software
and an agenda so anybody can do it and
all these tick talkers and youtubers
that have created a dark image of him
just to be provocative just to stir the
pot i can't wrap my head around having
the moral depravity to want to just stir
the pot just to stir the pot i can't
wrap my head around it and i'm still
trying but this man for everything i've
learned about him has not deserved that
yeah no you need to recognize that
everyone that everything everyone says
comes with an agenda especially when
it's on youtube or social media so a lot
of people would think that with tate
going viral all he's trying to do is
sell his university but is that really
the end goal or is his goal to get
famous and then do something greater out
of it like every youtuber is trying to
sell you something whether it's an
affiliate link a university whatever you
know what i mean right everyone has
their agenda and the reason why they're
doing what they're doing you know
genders aren't all bad though no it's
not it's definitely not all bad because
i'll admit my one of my agendas and
points of making social media is to like
have my online university and teach
people but i i admit to i'm not like
gonna hide but with the goal of taking
things that you've learned and making it
yeah something learnable and digestible
and make a difference in people's lives
like help people to make a difference
more importantly help people to make a
difference in their own lives yeah
exactly and that is that so there's an
agenda but it's it's not always a hidden
low-key dark web agenda like people have
cruelty in in their agendas that is
really disturbing yeah it's pretty
obvious obvious what i've been doing and
i've been pretty clever about it and
open you know it's like you're in high
school out there on the internet i mean
i remember like junior high there were
always just [ __ ] girls that were
starting stir in the pot and starting
rumors and you know for to any extent
that i participated in that i am
disgusted by it and regret it but what
are you going to do you're growing and
learning but i wasn't i wasn't a main
player in that but some people really
just like to start fights god it's
sickening poor tate so
i'm happy to let you speak for yourself
tell us what your message is to young
men
yeah so i think that being a man is very
very difficult
i think that men's issues are largely
overlooked
the people in charge of the world
pretend to care but when somebody who's
champion
champion championing men's issues like
myself comes forward and finally manages
to garner huge
percentiles of the public support i'm
silenced so they're not really
interested in men's issues and there's a
lot of young men growing up today that
feel very disaffected they feel
invisible
the agendas that are being forced down
their throats are not agendas they align
i'd like to hear in the comments if that
is if that comment of young men feeling
invisible resonates with the audience
that is watching our video i can
guarantee that that people resonate with
that i just for the first time yesterday
got a dm from a hot girl yesterday was
the first time someone's ever slid into
my dms
that's nice
let's [ __ ] go yeah but before that
whenever fish watch out no she's not
she's really hot but whenever you're a
regular dude even if you're like
especially good looking for the most
part you're [ __ ] dude you know what i
mean for men it's more about like status
and the thing i said is like if a man is
is sliding in a girl's dms he's not
looking at like when he's looking at her
account he's not looking at like oh she
plays volleyball oh oh she likes [ __ ]
soccer like no guys do not care about
that they're just looking at the girl
come on looking at the face in the body
when a girl is looking at a guy she's
looking at like what car he has how much
money he has oh he can take me to cool
places you know what i mean so you're
saying that those are the factors around
feeling invisible in society today or
it's just different i see it i
this is also just about how you know a
traditional male is is pushed to the
side by feminism lgbtq agendas political
agendas blah blah blah everything that
is you know being shoved down our
throats and you know the is there is
there enough talk about just regular
guys and i do think that they are
ironically being purposefully
marginalized yeah i don't i'll bug out
on me for that i don't want to hear it
but the yeah just let us know what you
think of it because we're i am very
curious to see those comments and i
basically just say to men look it's a
very hard life
you're going to need to get up work hard
go to the gym strong body is a strong
mind you're gonna have to reject
listening blindly to everything you're
told reject the slave mind think for
yourself get a strong network of
brothers work aside them don't tolerate
low quality people in your life which
means don't tolerate men who just smoke
drugs and play video games when i was
watching this with my friends last night
everyone was like yeah yeah until he
said that and then they were like oh
yeah the high-ends were here last night
it's okay like my thing is like it's
okay to have different friend groups
like like different types of friends so
like i have my friends that we do just
like stupid [ __ ] like where we just
smoking dude
and then i have my friends for the most
part like that's like the majority of
the people i'm spending my time with
that we're grinding and trying to make
money and better ourselves go to the gym
and that kind of stuff yeah i believe in
a little diversity and friendships
because it's fun you got to relax and
have everybody loosen up once yeah and
all the circles don't necessarily mix
thank you you don't you can't
necessarily invite all the friend groups
over at once because they don't always
go together and we all know that but
yeah yeah he's right i mean imagine if
if this is the kind of thing that was
taught to you from when you are a little
kid
actively every day be careful who you
choose who you're with you know choose
your friends carefully choose the people
who are successful and be hang around
them instead of just all the nonsense
you got to be friends with everybody no
you know or men who are disloyal or
dishonest by extension don't tolerate
women or girlfriends who are disloyal or
dishonest and try and build and create a
reality full of high quality people in
which you can resist the programming
that the matrix tries to
influence you with and grow up truly
happy and
what happens is when i say these things
they ignore 95 of what i say
they ignore me saying that you need to
avoid low quality men and they take the
bit where i say avoid women who are
dishonest and then they put it on a reel
a very short three or four second clip
and then they say i'm a misogynistic
person and i'm dangerous to women and i
need to be banned and it's truly
truly
i've i've explained in my final video
which i'd like to talk about i put a
video up it can be viewed now at
top g which www.freetopg my nickname top
g dot com and i explained at length we
also just reacted to that so i'll drop
the link in the description make sure to
go check it out
what has happened to me how it was done
and why it's not true
and everybody knows it's not true but
they've just come up with the spin that
i am somehow dangerous to women because
i tell men just to grow up and and be
the kind of man that we were all taught
to be in the 90s and 80s anyway i i
really i'm not saying anything
controversial on any level
well i you know i'm not grounded in your
work apart from seeing a few videos but
the message you just articulated
strikes me is the best possible message
it's hard to imagine who could disagree
with that to give our audience some
sense of the scale of your band tech
talk i don't believe you had a tick tock
account your videos were shared by
others on tick tock and they were one of
the most widely viewed categories on
tick tock android videos tick tock
apparently has banned any video of you
not just ones you release but ones in
which you appear so this is
really a reaction without precedent this
wasn't done to the isis beheading videos
what they've
what they've done uh to you
so i i i just want to press you a little
bit more on motive we're both
speculating but it's really interesting
what about
the message that you just articulated is
so threatening to the people who banned
you well i think that
and this is the true shame of it and i
want to make this very clear as a matter
of public record i have no interest in
going to war with social media companies
i had no interest in trying to
convert large swaths of the population
to one political party or another i had
no interest in that all i was doing is
was speaking from my personal experience
about the difficulties of growing up as
a man and how to get the best possible
life experience
as a man in the world today and when you
do that you unfortunately for them you
must teach people to resist the slave
mind and to think for themselves and
develop character and to learn how to
stand up and do the right thing even if
it's difficult and to not blindly accept
programming and to not be physically
weak and to not be mentally weak and
what you're doing is
i guess what i'm doing is i'm creating
people i'm creating millions and
millions of young men who simply won't
listen to lies or swallow the garbage
they're trying to feed them and they see
me as another way out they
they look at a youtube feed
and they see all the videos they're
supposed to like they don't like any of
them and i don't blame them they see me
and they're finally like wow somebody
who's aspirational somebody who's living
the life i want to live i want to be
like this guy
and they saw that as a threat i i made
it very difficult for them to program
the young men of the generation with
whatever they want to program them with
do you think he's one of the most
influential people to ever blow up i've
only recently learned about andrew tate
you have to remember in the last month
or so so i i can't speak to that yet but
i can tell you that right now there are
boomers watching this and i'm not a
boomer even though you call me one
sometimes
you're an elderly woman oh yes nico
that's right it's nico's got it nailed
there are boomers watching this that are
overjoyed that this guy is famous and
that this is coming out and that these
people somebody like tate exists and has
tens or hundreds of millions of
followers whatever it is probably tens
he has no followers he just has billions
of views fans you know what i mean and
for that reason they decided i was too
dangerous to exist and i must be
annihilated
if they truly cared about men's mental
health then they would have come to me
and said andrew tate you have huge
influence over a large percentage of the
population
we want to
we are unhappy with certain elements of
your messaging perhaps it needs creation
perhaps it needs editing but we
understand that
you are so respected and so many men
look up to you we can't possibly just
delete you from the internet that's bad
for men's mental health as a whole
you're championing issues which a lot of
men struggle with if they were worried
about women they could have approached
me with the same rhetoric instead they
just decided no let's completely
annihilate him and let me make something
very very clear
there is nobody
who is against me who has a genuine
concern
for women and i'll tell you this now
because i have no criminal record
i have never been arrested in any
country
and held on suspicion of anything
uh there were some incidents which i
talked about in my final video in which
i was swatted and accused of crimes i
didn't commit
but there are plenty of people on social
media with genuine criminal charges
against women i don't have any of these
things i haven't heard any women no
women have come forward saying i've hurt
them there's not a single female who's
making videos saying i hurt them in fact
quite the contrary there were videos on
youtube from women who know me very well
saying this is all false and this is not
fair
which have been deleted in real time by
the youtube censorship ever since i've
been banned
but
it's completely asinine and what they're
doing is they're weaponizing the idea of
misogyny they're pretending they care
about women and using it as an excuse to
cancel me and it's nothing to do with
women nobody is concerned for women
because there's no reason for concern
the truth is they just won't be gone if
they were really concerned about women
they let him continue to speak because
he preaches to men to protect women they
don't yes he does that he does they also
don't want to have a dialogue because
they if they were concerned they would
what he said let's have a conversation
about it but they also know that he
would eat them alive with his
level-headed clear logical thinking and
they have nothing but emotion and
name-calling even when he that's what's
ridiculous so they'll just call him a
misogynist because they cannot actually
beat him it's it's crazy even when he'd
go on um like twitch streams and stuff
all they'd argue about is stupid [ __ ]
like can women like are women better
drivers they wouldn't even argue about
like the real issues or
it was honestly never like very good
discussions it was like xqc like i need
to [ __ ] survive what if a bear she
can maybe sing to the bears like it was
so stupid you know what i mean he never
even got like good civil discourse
against someone who was like what's
happening yeah today is even with this
uh lausanne abi he's like yeah women can
drive better better than men actually
look at the statistics isn't that the
guy that just makes my stomach turn yeah
that kind of sucks it's like dude shut
up like bro obviously men are better
drivers than women obviously they have
quicker reaction times men are better at
stuff like video games
carry on we already talked about that
you're stupid you're saying that obvious
[ __ ] so news accounts in the united
states say that the u.s embassy in
bucharest romania
was tipped off
to your misdeeds and alerted the local
authorities you might be committing
human trafficking
um
given that this is the same charge they
leveled against julian assange or a
species of it you know skeptical but i
want to know the details were you what
about people like cardi b who's
literally drugged and and robbed people
and her face is put everywhere by these
platforms yeah they're okay with that
that's no problem she's a great role
model and skank she's dreaming
what happened
yeah i was not arrested so what happened
is i suffered from a case of swatting
it's very popular with people who are
large on the internet many large
youtubers
it's where you call the police and you
say somebody has a gun or there's a
hostage situation and the swat team
arrives
somebody made a phone call to the
american embassy saying i was holding
women at my house
the police arrived and let me state this
now i state this
uh openly to the world i have absolute
respect for the police i would hate to
live in a country where if you call the
police saying women are being held
against their will that the police don't
respond that would be terrible of course
they should come and look absolutely
they turned up they investigated they
realized that nobody was in the house
against their will there was no crime
committed they said okay you're not a
suspect but you are a witness to this
along with me my brother the housekeeper
uh the gardener everybody was in the
premises at the time was labeled a
witness
we had to go to the police station for
45 minutes for pieces of paper we filled
them in and we were let go i was swatted
nobody was hurt there's no human
trafficking there's no women who are
tied up there's none of these things
it's all just complete fallacy and
because i have a large number of
detractors on the internet they just
take that narrative and run with it he's
human traffickers human trafficker i
don't have any criminal charges i'm not
on bail i can travel the world freely
no women were hurt no women were found
but then the nature of the internet when
people dislike you and when the media is
trying to spin a narrative against you
they just take little clips they censor
the truth and they just try and spin it
up to the point where they convince the
world that i'm some extremely dangerous
man who manages to also evade all law
enforcement and run around hurting
people it's just not true and anyone
with a brain can sit here and realize
how the media and how law enforcement
can be weaponized against people
i've discussed this in long if anyone
who's interested to understand the true
story in my long format video
freetopg.com i explained exactly what
happened i was swatted like everybody
else but just because they put the tone
of human trafficking on it i'm now stuck
with this very unfortunate label and
it's truly disgusting i wonder what
labels we're gonna get when we finally
get canceled it's gonna happen
eventually some someone's gonna catch on
and try to try to kill us or some [ __ ]
you know uh let's hope not but
everybody's getting i wonder what
they're going to come after us for
though i'm pretty excited to see it
where are you from how did you get to
where you are now
i probably should get a little
background
sure let's talk about it i'm a mixed
race individual my father
was black he actually served in the air
force he was the five times
air force chess champion and he was a
chess master one of the best chess
players in the world
my mother is white and she is from
england i grew up in luton england which
is the worst town in england
um
to use liberal speak i am a person of
color i guess you can say that
i did not come from a privileged
background in any regard
my mother and father broke up i grew up
in a single mother household in luton
england
what do you mean and uh i worked very
hard i i went to school i obeyed i was
never a criminal i was never a juvenile
priest i trained very hard
too kickboxer became four-time
kickboxing world champion [ __ ] idiots
i retired from the sport
uh moved to romania which is a beautiful
country the irony is this dude should be
the left's biggest idol the one that
came out of those black [ __ ]
neighborhoods and made it big escape the
matrix like they this should be the guy
that they're looking up to look at this
african-american man that that that
overcame all of this stuff but no they
want you on welfare they want you
relying off the government and they want
you looking up to somebody like cardi b
so you can say right where you are or
worse it goes on and on
[ __ ] ridiculous skank kickboxing to
advising young men
online like how did that evolve yeah
that's a very good question i became the
most googled man on the planet recently
so i guess by some metrics you can call
me the most famous man on the planet
and that happened very simply because
i think that young men are are looking
for someone aspirational to look up to i
can only speak from my own personal
experience but
young men are very
we like to
emulate our heroes
and we look at somebody who we want to
be to some degree and that's the kind of
person we're going to listen to and
without that element of i want what he
has or i want to be like he is it's very
difficult for
young men to listen to anybody
and i think that there was a gap in the
market there's not very many people who
are out here
with a truly aspirational life
and truly speaking their mind right
because we live in the digital world now
where most of the famous people are very
afraid to talk there's literally nobody
like tate there's no leader or anyone
for people to look up to like tate even
when tristan tate passed the torch onto
stiko yeah i like sneaker i think he's a
great guy and he's really smart but he
does not have even close to the life
experiences tape and neither do i even
know i'm saying a lot of similar stuff
and i i there are people like tate
there's just nobody at his level of fame
and uh
social media presidents and as
articulate and good as talking as him i
mean he's one of the most interesting
people in the world to just he just sits
in front of a camera and talks for hours
and everyone listens to it how many
people do you know can just do that yeah
just literally sit in front of a camera
yeah i'm sorry there are some great
podcasters that have a similar set they
have wonderful like incredible life
stories and there are he's not the only
one if i'm filming a scripted video my
god i am stupid it takes me like six
tries to to say a line you know this
dude will just talk for three hours it's
incredible and i think i just stood up
and started saying the things that all
men think and
i also combined it with some
clever delivery a degree of humor
uh
comprehensiveness i worked very hard on
my social media presence and i also
threw in some locker room talk like i
understand
very well why the social media companies
have chosen the misogynistic angle but
the things i was saying
really i don't think were that offensive
i'd say oh you know women can't park or
some something that every
every man said in the locker room 10 15
years ago is truly not that genuinely
offensive and it's just spiraled now to
the point where on the most famous man
in the world and there's thousands of
tick tocks saying andrew said women
can't pop
it's just crazy it's truly media
sensationalism and they've tried to do
that because they want that all these
narratives pushed so they can ban me but
not 95 of my content is purely just
about mindset
fitness training there's nothing to do
with the things they're accusing me of
nothing at all
so they've hit you pretty exclusively
from what i can tell is you just said on
the women question you hate women
what is your view again i want to let
you speak for yourself
so and this is a really good question
and i i think in the modern world today
it's very unfortunate that if you tell
the truth about certain things people
are going to label you certain things
but i'm just going to be very honest
here on this platform i absolutely love
women i have nothing against women i've
said many times on many different
podcasts which they seem to want to
ignore that my mother is a hero of mine
i have nothing against women on any
level
i think that men and women are different
i think that we have different skill
sets i think that women are much better
than men at certain things and vice
versa and i think that if we work
together as a team
that we can be a beautiful
a beautiful synergy i think that's how
society functions best when a man takes
his role seriously and a woman takes her
role seriously and they work together as
a team
and i think that that's how society's
always been for the longest period of
human time i think outside of the west
that's the way the society still is
i don't think it's really controversial
to say that men are for example
physically stronger than women and women
are for example more empathetic than men
i don't think that's controversial
somehow that's managed to end up super
controversial and i've been accused of
being sexist and misogynist and all
these terrible things but i truly
believe these things and i don't believe
them in a negative connotation
i really don't i think a man has a duty
to provide for a female and protect her
and take care of her but even if you
disagree this is where it just goes back
to complete the complete insanity of
what we're living in if you disagree
with this just keep moving just either
politely disagree or get your [ __ ]
boyfriend or go just go do your own
thing you know what's so funny you don't
have to why do you why does everybody
have to agree with the left and anybody
that doesn't gets banned it's enough of
this [ __ ] and everyone's had enough if
you ask the ugly feminists about like
their opinion on women and like if
they're better than men or they should
be like the priority they'll literally
say yes they'll be like yes women are
the prize women are the queens and he's
saying the same thing he's saying to
protect them and provide and be a leader
and they just can't wrap their [ __ ]
stupid little heads around it sorry that
was rude but you know what i'm saying
it's not rude it is stupid they are
having they do have stupid illogical
heads some of the stupid the dumbest
breeds of people they literally think
that women are better and then when he
says it in a different way you said you
want to open the door for me you want to
you want to carry something heavy for me
i don't think i can open the door myself
myself you misogynist if you get it go
ahead you ugly broad you gotta go open
the door yourself like find a wife she
needs to pass the sunny bronze tail test
yeah that's the only way she needs to
open the door for you that's it unlock
the car door not be a selfish broad it's
a beautiful thing when a man does that
and i think the majority of women want a
man who does that i don't think they
want a man who wouldn't do that but by
stating these things and saying these
things
they have managed to twist my words
and change them into the idea that
andrew says women shouldn't have jobs
they should only live off their man's
money or andrew said that uh
men are two men are strong so women's
opinions don't matter or all these other
crazy twists of my language and it's
truly just been
um internet sensationalism i can talk at
length about why this has happened i
think it's a two-pronged attack
but one is there's certainly been an
agenda against me for a long time kate
has his phase two going live right now i
i have today soon i know no all right
we're gonna have to react to it
drop comment if you want to direct that
too we have to understand that social
media today is not the same as it was
four or five years ago we're now living
the generation of extremely short format
video tick tock is only a few seconds
long so is instagram reels so uh so is
youtube shorts and if you ever watch a
child on tick tock or you ever watch
anybody on tiktok look how quickly they
scroll if a video doesn't get their
interest in half a second they change
video so people are putting together the
most shocking sensationalistic things
they can to try and get likes and views
so nobody's interested in taking my long
format answers like i'm giving you now
and understanding me what they do
instead is they take that tiny clip
where i said men are stronger than women
and they put up a video of a guy
weightlifting and then they put up a
video of a girl failing to weight lift
and then they put up a laughing voice
hahahaha and then they throw it on tick
tock and now i'm misogynist but i didn't
make that video yeah the video is
misleading about his intent which is
again you know what stop okay stop i
will get up and walk out keep going no
you just infuriate me sometimes all just
ended up
culminating in this media storm of me
being a horrible misogynist who hates
women when i have no criminal charges
against women i've never struck a woman
in anger and every single woman coming
forward saying my name is saying the
absolute opposite it's truly clown world
truly
so i spoke to a a young man i know who
says that he first became aware of you a
couple of years ago and people in his
social circle became aware of you for
the same reason which is because you're
one of the only people on the internet
raising questions about the effects of
ssris
on young people what is that tell us
your view of that and why
yeah throughout the years i've been on
the internet antidepressants and i've
had a whole bunch of opinions some
controversial some otherwise and i've
always been a person who spoke my mind
um i say some things that people heavily
disagree with i'm i'm anti
uh uh antidepressants i don't believe in
antidepressant drugs i don't believe in
trying to take pills to alter your mood
because you feel anxious or unhappy or
depressed depressive
i was anti a bunch of things when it
comes to covid and the vaccine and such
i've been anti a bunch of these things
and i've just been talking my personal
view and my personal experiences
and i was never really looking to go to
war with any of these large tech giants
on any serious level i was just like
everybody else on the internet saying
what he truly believed this dude was
literally like at our current level like
eight months ago wow literally just a
regular ass guy talking and he blew up
this much that is so
insane tucker time it is mind-boggling
this is like not this is like the least
crazy thing he's done being on tucker
time i mean that's big but it's like
this dude literally it was like if not i
guess that is one or he's one of the top
like three or five points the highest
rated journalists bro best highest
one in three videos on my tick tock feed
that is 100 million times crazier than
being on tucker steve we live in a world
now where
information warfare is to true warfare
and narrative control is to true
narrative control sorry narrative
control is the true
weapon that the people in charge of the
world need to create and protect by
making sure they can control what people
see and how people think they can
genuinely affect reality in real time
and anybody who's a danger to that
narrative on any level
for them the risk isn't worth the reward
and it's better just to nuke that person
absolutely i don't know how i truly
ended up in that category because like i
said i'm just inspiring men to go to the
gym and train hard and and have
standards for themselves and speak up
for themselves the forgotten young men
of the world but that's where i've
somehow ended up could you imagine
wanting young men to sit home and cry
over social injustice instead of just
going out and becoming a better human
being could happen who was it who has it
all they want is is for you to be
distracted by [ __ ] by celebrity
drama i saw one like ellen's a mean
person
there's articles everywhere about that
who gives a [ __ ] who cares i wasn't
allowed to be an [ __ ] she's a human
being and how many celebrities are happy
because she wasn't even really an
[ __ ] we don't know but let's say for
the sake of the conversation she was
ellen you're allowed to be an [ __ ]
stop apologizing it's not even what it's
about
they distract you with stupid [ __ ]
headlines and a bunch of and a bunch of
bs so that you can't be distracted by
real problems and then they'll make up
problems like police killing black lives
like you're gonna [ __ ] die if you
leave the house completely untrue don't
be a [ __ ] criminal and you will mo 99
of the time you will be fine i'm gonna
get hate for it you're gonna be fine yes
i understand that black people like
there is we talked about this there's
problems once they enter the criminal
justice system but they're not they're
they are talking about black people
being killed by police as if it is
literally the biggest problem in the
biggest problem in america when it's not
even it's not even close it's not even
close they don't even talk about data
and numbers perspective so if you're
running around screaming that and you
haven't looked up the facts your whole
life is against how i'm just about
looking at the facts look at personal
experience i could literally like
there's people i know all the time that
are dying like that are just dying on
the streets it's the same thing happens
to white people all the time and that
that that stuff doesn't get any traction
because it doesn't fit their agenda you
got to back up and look at it all
doesn't matter
is division so if you can't see that the
agenda is division you're a divider it's
not even that i'm saying that it's not a
problem that black people get killed by
cops i'm saying it's not that they've
made it the biggest problem ever when
it's not because the same thing happens
to other races and there are literally
bigger problems and you're more likely
to die from other [ __ ] literally 90 like
almost almost 100 percent of the time
that people did on like like unjustly
died of cough they were like resisting
they had guns they were reaching for
knives and then they would just take the
clips out of context spin it and post it
everywhere that's what would happen
they're just trying to keep doing the
same [ __ ]
they just had to get control of people
i'm just sick of it i don't give a [ __ ]
i'll say my mind you know in general
i most of the time i speak about very
bland vanilla issues tucker i would love
to sit here and say that i've been the
most controversial man in the internet i
truly haven't it's it's it's really the
level of censorship i've been struck
with out of nowhere
is truly shocking and there's i can stay
here for everybody watching this if you
think that they won't get you if they
can ban me
they'll gonna ban ollie
especially if you live in the states
well you're certainly right you're
certainly right about that you made a
couple references to the mental health
of young men and you said you encouraged
them not to take drugs which strikes me
as the right message
why do you think so many young men have
mental health problems right now
well this is this is the problem is that
the majority of young men in the world
today are completely invisible and
social media has made them invisible if
you go into an instagram feed you have
extremely beautiful women which is fine
that's they're beautiful they're allowed
to take pictures but the only men who
have followers are men with massive
social status right men with ferraris
and money or rappers or people who have
youtube channels interesting people if
you're a normal man with a normal job
you don't really exist in the online
world it's very difficult to get
followers nobody replies to your dms you
don't really matter you don't have
access to the sexual marketplace it's
very difficult for you to even get any
kind of recognition that you're even
alive
yeah unless you have you are super
hilarious
or
you know talented in some way but he's
talking about through social media right
there so if you're a regular joe through
social media you're getting nothing and
people are on their phones 10 hours a
day so that's literally like a part of
your life is your social media life
that's why people are becoming depressed
a big part of it is because of social
media and also because they're
constantly promoting these narratives
making men weaker which ultimately just
hurts everyone and makes people
depressed they're killing traditional
values they don't want men to become
strong and independent people which
ultimately makes you happy men want to
conquer i love conquering i love getting
more subscribers every on my sunny fast
every view i see that it goes up that's
another [ __ ] see in my face like
i love that it's like stacking a brick
on a house that is such a great feeling
and so many people don't even
accomplishment there is so many people
don't even have that inside of them
anymore they're literally completely
fine with just working a regular
low-paying job smoking drinking with
like spending their money on smoking and
drinking and that's it that's their life
well they were there's a whole
generation of people who were who were
raised by parents who did everything for
them these are people who never had to
even even have basic chores around the
house and and learn that there's some
misery in life and learn that you have
to do things always that you don't want
to do in order so you can
you do what you got to do that you can
do what you want to do they never
learned that they only got to do what
they wanted to do so they've never had
any balance emotional balance they've
never had any sense of accomplishment
because how about the the free trophy
that everybody gets a trophy generation
you show up you know what i did i
snapped that [ __ ] in half i threw all
them out all of them even as a little
kid i talked to you and i would tell you
this means nothing the one where you
earned it you got mvp or you got you
know second place boy the year snapped
that [ __ ] in the locker room but not
even that like if you did something good
and you earned it that's one thing but
they just give trophies out to everybody
that shows up and you got this trophy
you have no sense of accomplishment you
have no pride in your work it means
nothing it's garbage and they did that
to try to make people feel good and
ultimately what they did is taught them
you don't have to accomplish anything
and their innate their natural instincts
to create to build those are human
instincts and they've tried to kill them
and they in order to make life easier
and now look what they've done they've
created a generation of people who are
have their instincts destroyed and they
are confused and depressed because of it
and it's a shame and they're smashed and
we have to build people back up again
and it's so much harder to build them
back up when you could have just built
them up from when they were born tate's
out there trying to do that but it
doesn't fit the narrative because again
strong people educated people who can
think for themselves and reason for
themselves again can't control them so
there are a lot of us out there though
that think for ourselves and will not be
controlled so they can kiss our asses
because it's not happening you can shut
us out of social media but if you think
you're going to control our lives you
can go hmm dude i'm getting sticking up
your ass i'm getting a straight itch
right now my boys are all texting me to
watch t on rumble i'm literally itching
like a jungle pause this and because i
can get ready and then you're going to
drive me to
what do you mean can we just finish
we're not going to finish this we have
we have 20 minutes left and i got a i
got another
[Music]
won't reservation long